I was recently asked to do a
collaboration with a well-known company
that sells gold-plated jewelry
it's not that I have anything against
the company itself
they have beautiful pieces and they make
an effort to use sustainable methods
but when I thought about why I
ultimately had to reject this offer I
realized that it was about more than
whether or not I would recommend a
particular product
and it is that there is an unspoken rule
for me when it comes to making purchases
that helps me to decide whether or not I
would purchase a particular product it
is the minimalist shopping rule I live
by hey guys I'm yesi and in today's
video I'm going to use the example of
jewelry just because it's what's been on
my mind but I think that this applies to
virtually any purchase in the past I
considered myself a smart shopper
because I would buy cheaper or snag a
sale so that I could have more whether
or not it was clothes home decor or
whatever I was always looking for the
cheaper price tags so that I could
continue to shop for more items shopping
was definitely a hobby for me and I was
constantly on the hunt for that new
statement top or that new purse that
would match those three inch heels that
I never wore and I fell prey to the BOGO
and discounts all the time thinking that
I was saving money my husband and I
began to adopt minimalism into our lives
after reading Dave Ramsey's book The
Total Money Makeover over it motivated
us to sell many of our belongings and
get out of debt my fun shopping was put
to a stop and I can definitely say with
confidence that I have decluttered at
least 80 percent of my wardrobe if not
more and I'm much happier for it but
when it came to purchasing new items I
initially had a very big struggle with
the concept that my dad had always
taught me he says I buy the nice thing
the first time so that I don't have to
buy it a second time but I was now a
Frugal Shopper gone minimalist and
saving money was my priority it seemed
totally counter-intuitive how is it
possible that I can save more money if I
spend more on the items that I buy for
me the answer lies in intentionality I
first had to ask myself what minimalism
means to me and for me it doesn't mean
living out of a backpack and never
allowing my kids to have a toy because I
don't want clutter the answer to that
question for me means that things must
be either useful for me or things that I
will enjoy but they must also check
another checkbox and that is that they
must be good quality even if it means
that I spend a little bit more in the
process so in the jewelry example I
can't in good conscience recommend that
somebody buy gold plated jewelry when I
know that it will tarnish it is not
something that you're going to want to
shower in every day or go swimming in
all the time and if you want to keep it
looking like the day that you bought it
you're gonna want to keep replating it
every couple of years or so where by
contrast if maybe you were to spend an
extra 100 or 200 you may be able to get
a similar piece in gold and it will
maintain its value meaning you can sell
it later on if you decide to do so and
not only will it last you a lifetime but
it can also be passed down for
Generations Anna is currently wearing
earrings that were mine when I was a
child that were passed down to me from
my aunt and provided that she doesn't
lose them she can pass them down to her
children or sell them for way more than
they were worth 50 years ago in an exam
people that's very relevant to my
husband in the construction work that he
does when we had first gotten married we
of course didn't have any money and so
we thought we were being smart Shoppers
by buying the cheaper alternatives to
power tools that he needed but it seemed
like we were constantly buying new tools
or replacing parts or even another
example for purchases around the home
take this reusable dish sponge for
example I spent around six or seven
dollars for a set of two and when
compared to the Disposable alternative
it is definitely much more expensive but
I haven't purchased a dish sponge for
over two years
so how many disposables would I have
spent in that period of time in this
scenario I'm getting more for my money
in the long run so sometimes when you
spend more on that item that's supposed
to last you a longer time you get more
for your money but not only that when
you're constantly buying more of the
lower quality version you also have to
take into consideration the time and
energy that you spend to and from the
store trying to get these items all the
time time that could be spent doing
other things and I want to clarify that
when I say words like the cheap version
or the better quality version I don't
mean that the higher quality necessarily
has to cost more for example I purchased
these Leather Coach gloves at a thrift
store for five dollars
Anna and John's trundle beds were also
used and cost 300 for both and allow for
extra beds when we have guests you can
also sell or trade items or work for the
things that you want to buy and DIY
projects can also save you some major
Cash Take This wooden mantle that my
husband made for example
it was practically free since we used
tools that we already had as well as
wood from a tree that we had cut down
when we built this house so if you want
or need to purchase something I'm not
saying that you should necessarily look
at the higher prize tag and think will
this cost me more so it must be better
quality but rather for those items that
you truly know that you will use for
years to come find a way to get the
higher quality versions so that you
don't have to be constantly replacing
these items over and over and over again
and this way you will save money in the
long run I think it's kind of ironic
that I was offered this collaboration
just when I had finally decided to
purchase gold earrings for myself but it
provides the perfect opportunity to talk
about something that's really important
to me because minimalism has really
helped me to practice a concept called
delayed gratification in this fast-paced
world we are so used to having things
instantly with overnight shipping and
instant transfers we tend to become
impatient
I have actually wanted gold hoop
earrings for years now and I still don't
have them
but I never really felt like it was
something that I have to have right now
because I know that I'll have them
eventually
I guess it just helps me ease the
constant desire for more
but for those items that I do want I'm
also not worried about the how or when
I'll have them because in my mind
they've already been given to me it's
just that future me is enjoying them
since adopting minimalism I can
definitely say that I'm a lot more
thoughtful and intentional about the
purchases that I make but I also can go
to The Other Extreme and overthink
things and overthinking purchases when
it comes to minimalism is just one of
those things that come with the
territory so having this simple rule
which is to consider cost per use and
consider the long run when you go to
purchase something can really be helpful
this helps me to avoid making purchases
based on how I feel in the short term
and to instead consider how they will
work out for me in the long run so from
tools to clothes to whatever else I
purchase just doing this has helped me
to avoid making mistake purchases and
has easily saved me thousands over the
years this simple rule has definitely
been helpful to me especially when I'm
trying to decide between like items to
buy so I hope they didn't share sharing
it it's been helpful to you and if you
want to hear more about making smart
financial decisions check out my two
videos my seven smartest financial
decisions that I made in my early 20s
and my seven dumbest purchases that I
made in my early 20s so maybe my
mistakes can show you what not to do
with your money I will link them both
down in the description if you like this
video and found it helpful please give
it a thumbs up and subscribe so you
won't miss when I post a new video I
thank you so much for watching and I
can't wait to see you in the next one
bye for now